hola de nuevo en el último vídeo
empezamos a hablar de cómo interpretar
la derivada parcial de una función que
representa a una superficie
parametrizado en este caso teníamos dos
variables de entrada y un vector de tres
variables de salida verdad y típicamente
visualizamos estos como superficies en
un espacio de tres dimensiones y todo en
este proceso digamos podríamos pensar
que teníamos una porción del plano ts y
vemos cómo se mueve al espacio de salida
verdad y nuevamente estamos aquí
haciendo un poco de trampa con esta
animación porque en realidad éste no es
el plano ts verdad este es el plano xy
en realidad deberíamos pensarlo como un
espacio separado y deberíamos ver cómo
se mueve a las tres dimensiones pero es
más difícil de animar de esta forma así
que simplemente nos vamos a quedar con
el plano xy de aquí y estaremos pensando
en este cuadrado donde t y s tienen un
rango que va de 0 a 3 verdad y lo que he
dicho es que la derivada parcial con
respecto a que si imaginamos esta línea
verdad que representa el movimiento en
la dirección de t vemos cómo se mapea a
todos estos puntos en el espacio de
salida es verdad y el vector de la
derivada parcial nos da
tangente a esta curva que representa a
la línea verdad y que corresponde al
movimiento en la dirección de t y
mientras más largo sea es más rápido el
movimiento mientras sería más sensible a
los pequeños empujoncitos en la
dirección de t en la dirección de s
verdad vamos a tomar digamos
vamos a borrar todo esto de aquí ok y si
en lugar de ver esto con respecto a t lo
vemos con respecto a s verdad entonces
consideramos la derivada parcial con
respecto a s verdad entonces aquí vamos
a tener algo muy similar diríamos bueno
cuál es la línea que corresponde al
movimiento en la dirección de ese y esta
que voy a dibujar va a ser perpendicular
a la que teníamos anteriormente verdad
porque está en el plano ts en este caso
la línea amarilla corresponde al valor
de t constante igual a 1 y dejamos a s
variar verdad y si vemos como se mate a
la línea a medida que nos movemos en el
espacio de entradas
tendremos puntos correspondientes en el
espacio de salida y esto nos dice qué es
lo que ocurre al variar s en la entrada
verdad se empieza a curvar muy interés
de forma muy interesante verdad
esta rejilla que tenemos aquí pintada
realmente nos ayuda porque cada vez que
vemos que las líneas de la rejilla se
intersectan una de estas líneas
representa el movimiento en la dirección
de t y la otra en la dirección de s y
para las derivadas parciales pensamos de
forma similar verdad pensamos que vamos
a pensar qué significa esta parcial con
respecto de s que entonces vamos a
acercarnos por acá la derivada parcial
respecto de s lo pensamos como si
representamos un un pequeño movimiento
en la dirección de s simplemente un
pequeño empujoncito verdad y luego
tendremos una un empujoncito
correspondiente en el espacio de salidas
verdad nos fijamos justamente en el
espacio de salidas y ahí tendremos
nuestro pequeño empujoncito verdad por
ejemplo podríamos pensar que nuestro
pequeño empujoncito en la entrada
corresponde a un vector tres veces más
grande quién sabe verdad digamos a lo
mejor se están estirando las cosas
verdad a lo mejor puede ser que sean más
tres veces más grande pero el punto es
que es un vector verdad y lo que hacemos
es pensar a este vector como en nuestra
derivada parcial de b
efecto de es el resultado que obtenemos
es un vector tangente que en realidad no
es un vector pequeño verdad sino que
ésta es un vector suficientemente grande
de verdad y esto corresponde a la tasa a
la que cambia no sólo con pequeños
cambios sino la casa la tasa de cambio
con respecto a no estaba a nuestra
variable es de verdad el que se genera
por el movimiento en esta dirección pero
en el espacio de salidas así que vamos a
calcular esto para este esta función que
tenemos aquí sólo para tener práctica
calculando este tipo de cosas así que si
nos fijamos aquí la variable t ahora es
una constante verdad así que la derivada
aquí es cero y sólo hay que derivar
menos s cuadrada eso nos queda menos 2 s
verdad si nos vamos a la siguiente
componente ese es la variable t es
constante entonces al derivar esto nos
queda solo t ahora tendremos derivada de
dts cuadrada es dos veces por s dos
veces este por s menos la derivada de
esto sería t cuadrada verdad porque éste
es constante y ese es nuestra variable y
al d
s nos da 1 y si ahora evaluamos en el
punto 11 que es nuestro punto rojo de
aquí entonces o tren obtendríamos que
aquí sería menos 2 por 1 es menos 21
verdad y 2 por uno por uno menos uno al
cuadrado es dos por uno por uno menos
uno al cuadrado entonces tendríamos dos
menos uno que es 1 así que cuando nos
fijamos en el vector de la derivada
parcial la componente x debe ser
negativa y las componentes jay-z ambas
deben ser positivas y si nos fijamos
aquí en la en la animación verdad
al ver el movimiento a lo largo de la
curva todo encaja verdad porque si nos
movemos a lo largo de esta curva nos
fijamos en la componente x verdad y esa
debe ser negativa porque nos estamos
moviendo hacia la izquierda ahora si nos
fijamos en la dirección de y podemos ver
que nos estamos moviendo hacia arriba
verdad y de hecho nos movemos a la
izquierda el doble de rápido que cuando
nos movemos hacia arriba y para la
componente zeta verdad de hecho nos
estamos moviendo justamente también
hacia arriba entonces vamos bien pero
también podríamos preguntarnos es real
en qué dirección nos estamos moviendo y
allí digamos el beneficio de la
animación aquí es que podríamos fijarnos
muy bien en cómo se mueve esta curva
verdad aquí tenemos ese que va desde 0 a
3 y podemos ver muy bien cuál es el
movimiento que corresponde a esta curva
y si le echaron un buen ojo pueden ver
que nuestro vector de la derivada
parcial apunta justo en la dirección que
se mueve la curva verdad y una cosa muy
bonita que podemos ver aquí es que
nuestras dos derivadas parciales que
hemos encontrado podríamos pensar que
cada una de ellas es un vector tangente
a la superficie verdad así que una es la
derivada parcial con respecto a t y la
otra es en la otra dirección verdad es
la la derivada parcial respecto de ese y
entonces tenemos vectores tangentes a la
superficie entonces podríamos pensar
también en una derivada direccional
verdad algo que combine estas dos formas
en las que nos podemos mover en los
vectores tangentes a la superficie y
hablaremos de esto más adelante cuando
hablemos de planos tangentes para poder
expresar de hecho la ecuación de un
plano tangente pero esto es todo lo que
necesita saber sobre las derivadas
parcial
de superficies parametrizados y en los
próximos vídeos hablaremos de las
derivadas parciales pero de funciones
con valores vectoriales en otros
contextos porque quizás no siempre
estamos pensando en curvas que se van
moviendo verdad aún queremos pensar cómo
es que este tipo de pequeños
empujoncitos corresponden a otros
empujoncitos en el espacio de salidas y
cuál sería la proporción entre ellos así
que con esto nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo